okay today I'm going to talk to you
about stem cells we're going to talk
about what stem cells are good look at
stem cells in animals and stem cells in
plants we're gonna look at have a look
at the medical uses of stem cells and
some of the barriers to being able to
use themselves in medicine as well so
first of all stem cells are cells which
are described as being undifferentiated
or unspecialized this just means that
they don't have a specific job yet they
have the ability to become more
potentials become a number of different
types of cell so first of all we're
gonna have a look at what
differentiation means so in our bodies
we have lots and lots of different types
of specialized cell so which could do
different jobs so a stem cell is a cell
which is unspecialized the cell which
currently has no job it can become
different types of cells depending on
what its kind of given instructions to
do within the body so for example it
could become a neuron in order to carry
electrical signals it could become some
cardiac muscle in the heart it could
become a red blood cell or it could for
example become a silly eight itself so
there's lots and lots of different types
of specialized cell in the body and they
all have particular jobs the stem cell
is the undifferentiated unspecialized
version that we get the beginning so one
type of stem cells is called
embryonic stem cells now embryonic stem
cells come from embryos that's the name
of the ball of cells the verr developing
ball of cells that will become a fetus
and then a baby so just after
fertilization we have an embryo and all
of those cells are unspecialized they
have the potential to become any type of
cell in the body so literally anytime
that's one type of stem cell the other
type of stem cells are called adult stem
cells so they're found in the body and
essentially adult stem cells are used in
order to produce a narrow range of cells
to replace damaged cells so adult stem
cells are slightly less useful because
they have a limited they have a limited
kind of different options of what they
can become
whereas embryonic stem cells can become
anything at all they're found for
example adults themselves in the bone
marrow now it's not just animal cells
that have stem cells plants also have
stem cells called Mary stems so the big
clue that stem cells it has the word
stem in it so I just show you where
where these stem cells are fine so if we
imagine I just have a little plant here
there's the plant above the ground and
this is obviously the roots below the
ground so we find Mary stems in the tip
of the root and within the tip of the
shoes so these Mary stems can become any
type of cell any type of plant cell so
there and these this can happen
throughout the lifetime without
throughout the whole lifetime of of the
plant so a type of an example of
specialized cell in a plant could be for
example xylem and phloem which transport
substances around the plant so if these
parts here they're tips the chute and
the tips of the root this is where we
find meristems which are
undifferentiated unspecialized plant
cells so what's the big deal about stem
cells how could they actually be used so
their potential uses are for example in
sick or cell anemia now these this is
when someone's born with a condition
where their red blood cells are
misshapen if they can have adult stem
cells put within their bone marrow those
cells can produce healthy red blood
cells it's just really useful stem cells
in the future could be used for spinal
cord injury
this could be extremely important if
someone has a spinal cord injury they
might well be paralyzed if we could put
an undifferentiated stem cell into their
spinal cord they could develop and grow
neurons develop into neurons which could
replace the damage it could also be used
for heart disease so if part of the
heart has been killed or died because of
disease we could potentially use stem
cells which would develop into cardiac
tissue so there's lots of potential uses
lots of different types of injury
ourselves could be just replaced by
using stem cells so what's the problem
why aren't these just used now so
problems first of all big problem is
ethics because embryonic stem cells come
from embryos which are the ball of cells
that will develop into a fetus and then
a baby so lots of people say that is
it's not right to be able to to use
embryonic stem cells because a lot of
people suggest that it's like taking a
life because that embryo would develop
into a person so there's a lot of
ethical issues around using embryonic
skin stem cells which are the more
useful typist themselves also a big
problem is tumors because if we've
introduced stem cell we want it to
divide it could it's very difficult to
control that division it could just keep
dividing and dividing and dividing and
form a tumor which could cause big big
problems next up is disease if whatever
reason somehow there was a virus within
a stem cell and we've planted it at
someone's body we'd be giving them that
particular disease and the final problem
is rejection if we put a stem cell or
stem cells into someone's body their
body may well recognize it as being
foreign and tried to destroy it the
white blood cells might try and break it
down so the stem cells may well be
rejected so that is
basically the summary sheet that is stem
cells summarized I hope it's been useful
thank you